we begin with this news major news I'll
read the post-millennial report because
I don't know how well the audio will
translate if you can't see the subtitles
but you should go and watch the full
video after the show this is the report
though from uh post Millennials project
Veritas released a new video Wednesday
in which a Pfizer executive claimed the
company is attempting to mutate kovid
via directed evolution in order to
preempt the development of future
vaccines
as a result hashtag directedevolution
trended worldwide Jordan Tristan Walker
Pfizer's director of research and
development strategic operations and an
mRNA scientific planner claimed that
direct evolution is not the same as gain
of function research which according to
the outlet is defined as a mutation that
confers new or enhanced activity on a
protein many of the virus in question
can become more powerful depending on
the mutation or scientific enhancement
Walker told an undercover project
Veritas journalist quote one of the
things that we Pfizer are exploring is
like why don't we just mutate covet
ourselves so we could create
preemptively uh new vaccines right so we
have to do that if we're going to do
that though there's a risk of like as
you could imagine no one wants to be
having a Pharma company mutating effing
viruses
he added
from what I've heard is they the Pfizer
scientists are optimizing the coveted
mutation process but they're going slow
because everyone is very cautious
obviously they don't want to accelerate
it too much I think they're also just
trying to do it as an exploratory thing
because you obviously don't want to
advertise that you're figuring out
future mutations
and then Walker pleaded don't tell
anyone promise you won't tell anyone the
way the experiment will work is that
we'd put the virus in monkeys and we
successfully caused them to successfully
successively cause them to keep
infecting each other and we collect
cereal samples from them
you have to be very controlled to make
sure this virus that you mutate doesn't
create something that just goes
everywhere which I suspect is the way
that the virus started in Wuhan to be
honest it makes no sense that this virus
popped out of nowhere it's BS okay like
I said you could watch this whole but I
think it's about 10 minutes
you see this whole conversation
um
where a Pfizer executive is saying that
they intend to do the same thing they
did in Wuhan but we gotta be really
careful
it's like the the the
uh
the safety of the human race is at stake
and we're just going to trust that you
know Pfizer is careful
like they can do things that if it goes
wrong Millions will die
but it's all right because we could just
trust them to be careful
because we know that these people
historically have been very careful
right
now
uh I mean this obviously should be
breaking news in every media Outlet we
have a high ranking official advisor
admitting that they're working on
mutating the virus admitting that it's
the same kind of thing they do Wuhan
pleading that uh that nobody finds out
about it it's like how much more
explicit can you be yes we're doing this
dangerous dangerous thing please don't
tell anyone we're doing it
what else do you need to hear
big Pharma
must be stopped and I'm not interested
in voting for any Republican who isn't
serious about holding these psychos
accountable they've been operating with
impunity for way too long
way before covet way before covet
okay before covet came along before the
game before the vaccines came along
how about turning half the country into
drug addicts inventing diseases to treat
and profit off of
conducting dangerous experiments that
imperil the human race
injecting whatever they want into our
bodies lying about it the whole time
it's got to stop and we need Leaders
with the wherewithal to stop it
now I've already told you we talked
yesterday about about the the penalties
that I would prefer to see for drug
traffickers
so you know what I would like to do with
drug traffickers well let's start here I
mean let's start with the ones who wear
suits and have offices on the top floor
of fancy skyrises I mean after we try
them for their crimes and convict them
in a court of law
because that has to be the first step
we're way past the point of uh
Congressional hearings and
investigations we need both of those
things
but they don't mean anything if they
don't lead to trials and
criminal charges convictions punishments
and there are other actual policy
changes too that could be made if we
really wanted to rein in big Pharma
and some of this might seem slightly
indirect
but but really it's not and we need to
be doing it raining in big Pharma right
means uh either it means it's simply a
talking point something that you say but
if it's more than to talk about it means
it means cutting off the funds it means
taking money away from these people
that's how you do it
or that is at least a major part of any
effective plan to rein them in
another big part is
again criminal charges trials
punishments you got to take the money
away and I'll tell you one way to do
that we've talked about this plenty of
times on this show
ban the pharmaceutical companies from
advertising their products directly to
Consumers
um whether it's a pill that they're
pushing or a vaccine or anything
they should not be allowed to advertise
it directly to Consumers and that's that
is already the policy in almost every
country in the world
almost every country in the world most
countries they don't let the
pharmaceutical companies advertise
directly to Consumers that was the
policy in this country until I think it
was the mid 90s when the FDA changed it
the fact that this policy was changed
and has not been changed back
the fact that we we uh still allow them
to advertise to Consumers only shows you
that our politicians are in their
pockets because there's no good argument
for allowing this
I just write an article a couple days
ago and um I'll pull it up maybe
tomorrow we'll talk about this in more
detail because it's very important but
basically
you know according to this uh this
article
the drugs there's kind of an inverse
correlation here because the drugs with
the biggest ad budgets have the lowest
therapeutic value
and why is that
because drugs that work
and are safe
are actually safe and actually effective
they don't need to be advertised doctors
will prescribe them because they work
there's no reason to advertise it
okay if the drug works and it's
effective in all that then you don't
need to go to your doctor and ask about
it can I have this drug
no especially you go to the doctor with
your symptoms and and then your your
your illness is diagnosed and treated
but drugs that don't work need
advertising because they need you as the
patient to go to your doctor and ask for
them
and then they need to incentivize the
medical industry to distribute these
drugs whether they work or not
and the other thing that they do with
these uh with these advertisements
the drug adds
they're not just selling drugs that are
ineffective and potentially dangerous I
mean they're doing that
but they're also selling the disease
they sell the disease
right that's why all the ads are the
same they say do you have this XYZ
symptom well talk to your doctor about
this drug
they're not even asking you oh well if
you already have this disease here's a
drug for you it's like
let's convince you that you have this
disease
a disease that you might not actually
have diseases that might not even exist
because big Pharma they also invent
diseases that don't exist so that they
can treat them and profit off of them
and then once they've uh toyed with your
hypochondriac mind and convince you you
have this thing you go to the doctor and
you plead for the for the the pills that
uh that you want and then most of the
time you get it
um it there is no good reason to allow
this there is just no good reason to the
only reason to allow the drug companies
to advertise directly to Consumers is is
if you're very concerned about making
sure that the big Pharma Executives make
a lot of money that's the only benefit
the only benefit is that they make tons
of money doing this if you don't let
them do it they make a lot less money
there is no benefit to the to the
population there's no benefit to me or
you
it's only harm
I bring all that up because uh again
this is one way you reign in big Pharma
but also if you're wondering why nothing
is being done by the powers that be
um to hold big Pharma accountable
when it comes to covid and the vaccine
and the lies that we're told if you're
wondering why all you need to look at
is is is is this I mean
direct consumer Banning direct consumer
ads that should be a bipartisan this
should be one of those very rare
bipartisan issues because it should
appeal to both sides
the right pretends to be skeptical of
the pharmaceutical industry the left
pretends to be skeptical of Corporations
and corporate greed in general well here
you go here's an issue that both sides
should agree on
and they don't at least not in
Washington
because obviously they're in the pockets
of these of this industry
on both sides
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]